I have a rare genetic condition called EXP which means I can't go out in the sun
It's not gonna fall into remission impossible and every year the risk becomes more serious, so I'm stuck inside all day and up all night
What should I have said? Hey, I watched outside at my window for the past 10 years. I've been stalking you
I'm Charlie. Katie ! You would want to do something sometime, would you? I'm really busy during the day, but make you pay for your night
What does Katie Perry want to do? There's so many things? I wanna do
I am not comfortable with him not knowing, I just need a little longer being someone more than just diseased
This isn't something you can just not tell me? I'm so sorry
Katie we're not the couple who doesn't try
Having someone that's the best part
new